[Applause]  [Applause]  on the night of April 2nd I had a dream  I was in a paradise I was in paradise  and I was playing in the ocean water  when air when air me is popped up right  behind me he said what up Killa so  that's my nickname too  I turned around and I yelled his name  and I gave him a hug  shortly he was gone but I was so what I  told my mom about the dream and after I  told her I was thinking about it and I  realized that amy has told me what  heaven was like he told me it was  paradise so in the morning areas would  say respect at the window so on my count  of three I want everybody to yell  respect three two one  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  in memory of Hermes asked Adam August 15  1985 to 2000 19 March 31st  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  give a kid some love their little  nervous  [Applause]